F
INSANITY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LAST NIGHT PREDICTED THAT MOST
DEMOCRATS WOULD GLEAN ALL THE
WRONG LESSONS FROM THEIR
REPUBLICAN VICTORIES AND TODAY,
I WAS PROVEN RIGHT.
THE PROGRESSIVES WERE BACK AT IT
ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY INSTEAD OF
HITTING THE BRAKES ON THEIR
RADICAL SPENDING SPREE, THEY
WANT TO SLAM ON THE ACCELERATOR.
>> IS IT FOR YOUR AGENDA?
>> PAID FAMILY LEAVE GOING BACK
INTO THE BILL WITHOUT
JOE MANCHIN'S OKAY.
>> I AM SO EXCITED THAT IT IS
GOING BACK IN THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN A PRIORITY OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS FOR A LONG
TIME AND WE ARE THRILLED.
>> TERRY McAULIFFE HAS BEEN
SAYING FOR WEEKS, TIED TO THE
PROGRESS OF NEGOTIATIONS HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL AND THERE OUGHT TO
BE A CLEAR MESSAGE.
>> WHAT WENT WRONG LAST NIGHT?
>> FAILURE TO DELIVER.
>> Laura: ALL WRONG.
STILL MISS READING THE
ELECTORATE.
BERNIE SANDERS WAS NOT ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
BIDEN WAS.
THERE WAS A FAILURE TO DELIVER
BUT TERRY McAULIFFE TURNED OUT
A RECORD NUMBER OF DEMOCRAT
VOTERS.
BUT THE PROBLEM WAS REPUBLICANS
CAME OUT IN BIGGER NUMBERS AND
NOT FOR SPENDING TRILLIONS ON
NEW ENTITLEMENTS OR AMNESTY FOR
ILLEGALS AND INTO OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
NONE OF THAT.
THIS WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
EXCHANGES OF THE DAY WITH A
LIBERAL PROGRESSIVE MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
EVEN THE CNN ANCHOR SEEMED
EXASPERATED.
>> WHAT LESSONS CAN BE LEARNED
FROM THE VIRGINIA RACE?
>> NUMBER ONE THING THEY WANTED
DEMOCRATS WITH MAJORITIES TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET IT DONE BEFORE
THE VIRGINIA RACE BECAUSE THEY
WERE HOLDING UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
>> I'M A JOURNALISM MAJOR.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ASK ME WHEN
WE ARE GOING TO PASS THE BILL OR
REPORT IS.
>> IT WAS PASSED IN AUGUST.
IT'S BEEN FOUR MONTHS, SO THAT
COULD HAVE ACTUALLY CREATED --
DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE SAID THEY
PASSED SOMETHING --
>> YOU GUYS ARE ALL AN ANXIOUS
SORT.
>> I'M SAYING YOU CAN RUN ON A
MESSAGE OF --
>> IF YOU LET ME FINISH.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> IF A LOT EASIER IF I'M
ALLOWED TO TOGGLES ALSO.
>> I'VE GIVEN YOU PLENTY OF
TIME.
>> WE NOW HAVE PAID FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE FOR FOUR WEEKS IN
THE BILL --
>> BUT YOU KNOW, SENATOR --
>> PEOPLE WILL FEEL THAT.
WHAT WE CALL THIS IS THE STORM
BEFORE THE CALM.
>> Laura: THE MAN SITS ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND HE
THINKS NEXT YEAR IS GOING TO BE
THE CALM?
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO SPEND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
EVENTUALLY JUST MAKE ENERGY MORE
AND MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN?
BY THE WAY, MAGICALLY, THE NEW
CLIMATE CORPS WILL MIRACULOUSLY
MAKE INFLATION DISAPPEAR.
ISN'T THAT GREAT TRICK?
VOTERS IN VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY ARE NOT STUPID.
THEY KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI,
CHUCK SCHUMER, THE WHOLE CREW
WANT TO DO AND THEY KNOW IT'S
GOING TO CAUSE MORE INFLATION
AND LOWER THE STANDARD OF LIVING
FOR EVERYONE BUT THE VERY RICH
OR THE VERY WELL-CONNECTED.
SUBURBAN MOMS CARED A LOT ABOUT
EDUCATION, FOR SURE, BUT THE
ECONOMY, SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES,
EMPTY STORES ON CHRISTMAS, THAT
BOTHERS THEM A HECK OF A LOT
TOO.
DEMOCRATS MANAGED TO EVEN LOSE
75TH HOUSE OF DELEGATES DISTRICT
IN VIRGINIA, WHICH IS MAJORITY
BLACK.
OF COURSE, THE VERY FORCES THAT
DRAG THE DEMOCRATS DOWN, THOUGH,
ARE STILL BETTING IT ALL ON THE
RACE ISSUE.
>> YOUNGKIN LED THE RACE CARD
FOR A REASON BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IT WORKS ON CERTAIN WHITE
VOTERS.
>> RACISM RAISED ITS UGLY HEAD
AND THE CANDIDATE USED IT
ACCURATELY.
>> FEEDING THEM ANGER AND
RESENTMENT.
BECAUSE SOME OF IT WAS DOG
WHISTLE RACISM.
>> 1000%.
>> Laura: TIME FOR A BIDEN
IMPERSONATION.
IT'S NOT WORKING.
THE EXAMPLE OF THE JAMAICAN BORN
WINSOME SERIES, YOU JUST SAW HER
ON SEAN HANNITY, VIRGINIA'S NEW
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
SHE MAKES THEM ALL LOOK LIKE
FROGS.
OH, AND A FEW WERE TALKING ABOUT
CUBAN-AMERICAN JASON MAYOR IS
WHO WON THE RACE FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN VIRGINIA.
BOTH ARE FIRST IN THE
OLD DOMINION BUT OF COURSE WE
KNOW DEMOCRATS ONLY PRATTLE ON
ABOUT FIRSTS WHEN THEY ARE ON
THEIR TEAM.
THE POPULIST CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT WAS ALREADY GAINING
HISPANIC SUPPORT UNDER TRUMP AND
THAT SUPPORT IS ONLY GROWING.
JOHN TRINITY OF REAL CLEAR
POLITICS NOTED THAT THE SHIFTS
OF NEW JERSEY SHOULD BE MUCH
MORE CONCERNING TO DEMOCRATS
THAN THE MORE OR LESS UNIFORM
SWING WE SAW IN VIRGINIA.
BIGGEST SWINGS FROM 2017 ARE IN
HEAVILY HISPANIC AREAS.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THE HISPANIC ISSUE LATER
ON IN THE SHOW BUT SOMEHOW,
DEMOCRATS CONCLUDE THAT THE WAY
TO STOP THE BLEEDING WITH
HISPANIC VOTERS IS TO SPEND
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND UNIVERSAL
PRE-K?
AND HOW EXACTLY WILL HISPANIC
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, AND THERE
ARE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS,
STAY FULLY STAFFED WHEN DEMOCRAT
POLICIES WOULD JUST MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO STAY HOME
LONGER.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS SHEER
MADNESS.
TRIM SPREE PRECOVET ECONOMIC
SUCCESS DEMONSTRATED HOW
TO DO IT.
HE DID IT.
THE FACT IS DEMOCRATS LONG AGO
LOST TOUCH WITH THE BEATING
HEART OF MIDDLE AMERICA, THE
MIDDLE CLASS, THE BLUE-COLLAR
WORK FOR US JOBS WERE DEPORTED
OVERSEAS AND THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEIR FATHERS AND SONS ARE DYING
OF DRUGS CROSSING OUR BORDER AND
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF VACCINE MANDATES BUT
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE, THEY
WROTE THE VACCINE MANDATES.
NOW THE SAME BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS
ARE STRUGGLING TO FILL UP THEIR
GAS TANKS AND NO ONE ON THE LEFT
CARES.
PERHAPS DEMOCRATS SHOULD
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST
TIME THEY RAN THROUGH THEIR
DREAM LEGISLATION DESPITE HAVING
ZERO REPUBLICAN SUPPORT.
>> YOU SEE ALL THAT READ, ALL
THAT FLASHING AT HOME, THOSE OF
REPUBLICAN PICKUPS AND WE ARE
NOWHERE NEAR FINISHED, WE DO
KNOW THEY WILL WIN MORE THAN 50
SEATS, MOST LIKELY MORE THAN 60
AND IT IS EVERYWHERE.
NORTH, WEST, SOUTH, IT IS A
SHELLACKING.
>> Laura: THE 2010 RESULTS
WERE A TOTAL REJECTION OF
OBAMACARE BUT OBAMA DIDN'T TRY
TO DODGE RESPONSIBILITY.
>> THIS VOTE CONFIRMED WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM FOLKS ALL ACROSS
AMERICA.
PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED, THEY ARE
DEEPLY FRUSTRATED WITH THE PACE
OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY HOPE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN AND AS PRESIDENT I
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
>> Laura: TODAY OF COURSE, HIS
VEEP FOR EIGHT YEARS REFUSED TO
TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Reporter: YOU TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBLE TO?
>> I'M NOT SURE I WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO CHANGE THE NUMBER
OF VERY CONSERVATIVE FOLKS WHO
TURNED OUT IN RED DISTRICTS WHO
WERE TRUMP VOTERS, BUT MAY BE
MAYBE.
I KNOW WE DID, BUT ALSO, I WAS
RUNNING AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: THAT IS SUCH AN
EMBARRASSING ANSWER.
BUT WHILE THE DEMOCRATS'S
WILLFUL IGNORANCE IS A BOON TO
REPUBLICANS, AND IT IS, IT IS
GOING TO BE TERRIBLE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THOSE WHO LEAST DESERVE TO
SUFFER WILL BE FORCED TO SUFFER.
THOSE WHO LEAST DESERVE A BIG
PAYDAY WILL GET ONE.
BUT A YEAR FROM NOW ALL
AMERICANS WILL HAVE THEIR SAY IN
THE MIDTERMS AND THE DAY AFTER,
THE SAME EXPERTS KEEP GETTING
PAID TO BE WRONG WILL AGAIN TRY
TO EXPLAIN AWAY THE DEMOCRAT
DEFEAT.
NEVER ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IT IS
BECAUSE THEIR P